the sub gap is over 9,000 that's a meme
good meme Phillies it ain't over till I
say it's over
for real though I'm really proud of
everyone I can't believe we made it this
far it's honest me an achievement just
never give up I'm not giving up until
t-series goes up there will be no more
brofist I'm serious I didn't think I
would have to do this no more brofist
until t-series gets deleted gets
completely annihilated I didn't want to
sink this low but I guess I have no
choice huh do you know how much it's
gonna mean to get that brofist here try
it
stop I was a test you dumb ball until
then let's get into the memes guys leave
your entry in us already closed another
week another meme everyone let's just
hello everyone
yah when you just ended being a meme but
then you become a meme again it's free
one-time incredible
I'm sorry Will Smith you can't rewind
your career though unless you go on meme
review I drew peopIe for 24 hours
straight goddamn I haven't even done
anything for myself for that long I did
what I could to help small youtuber zhc
say this is what I'm talking about I
understand that you look at your own
life and what you do to be completely
insignificant and I 100% agree with that
by assessment by the way but if we all
work together if we all do our part we
can do amazing things
look at this pale arm look at me whoa
holy damn ticks Harry sub
mims very nice god damn that's crazy
Bravo incredible that's so sick
YouTube copyright problem oh great
another week another copyright issue
what is it now
yo just got a copyright strike who the F
is two objects one and why can't I get
more details guy who strike me has one
sub and one upload what the frack you -
Lannon I'm sorry man just stop stealing
pour two objects ones content alright
this is the YouTube copyright system
it's it's free-for-all okay it's
everyone against everyone just MIT Puetz
ten out of ten
thank you for raiding my acquaintance
ten out of ten very nice also can
confirm he has no legs and was hovering
well well well I think this finally
settles it doesn't it huh all you
doubters and haters and manners well
well well couldn't come concrete
evidence
I expect normal rumors and no more lies
being spread around this a lot of people
have been complaining about the camera
quality and like how the autofocus is
wrong I just want to say I'm doing my
best here guys okay I think I'm gonna
change up my framing I'm gonna do it
like the twitch girls do I mean like the
people and websites this is my new crop
just so you guys can see the merch
better new merch everyone link in the
description alright
this is what you get now you've what
you've done you did this to yourself
for the last month we have been making
true Christian minecraft server to get
all minecrafters to sub to party what
sub to Pvt pine
after a month of work goddamn we finally
made a server that entirely runs on
memes Wow earn up boats from memes
it's a reddit inside my incredible money
goes to charity and the other 50% goes
to me that's awesome thanks guys thanks
guys thank you roblox oh yeah okay so
this is our other live streams we've
done minecraft oh god happy wheels god
dammit we have happy wheels I thought it
was done after minecraft but I guess I
will
cuz I'm doing my part after I wake up
every day doing my part I punch in
alright let's move on amazing trip to
Iceland Wow first date with my fiance in
almost two months was a success it's no
longer Felix its dr. Felix Thank You
Guzman very cool I would love to see a
video without the man come on let's make
it happen
subscribe to PewDiePie you did it you
crazy son of a gun you did it Thank You
jacksepticeye I was worried there for a
second life you wouldn't gonna do your
part but this is what I'm talking man
how we got to go say Masoud
jacksepticeye son thank you very much
it's what that means in nihongo sub gap
closes in nine-year-olds panic youtuber
youtuber joins the fight and sub gap
increase
we're gonna go forever the saga will go
on forever until CT series goes and then
you will get a breakfast here alright
I'll give you a sample just so you know
how we feel like pound it right in 3 3 2
1 what are you stupid
I said no breakfasts until we beat the
reeds Felix is angry about his height
but he doesn't realize the true power
holds 177 centimeters is 6969 oh my god
this gives my life completely new
meaning and satisfaction thank you Wow
69 I'll tell you by the way 69 69 what
69 69 what do you mean how tall are you
I don't want to have sex with you play
16 us I met the king himself in Iceland
at the place where I'm working I was
waiting for this moment since I was 1
years old Wow incredible it's been 8
years
sorry every night and drew to myself I
was nervous as a freak my name Alex well
it was nice to meet you Alex I remember
you it was very nice why do I look so
awkward like Jesus Christ I just want to
know one thing what's your height he
replies 188 to 190 oh-oh-oh m1 77 they
said I knew Joe will mess with the tip
measuring tape look look here lookee
here same height same height that's a
straight line so that means I'm 190 so
everyone's saying I'm a man like
everyone saying I'm sure you don't know
I would even argue that I'm alone
I'm a little taller actually look
straight line straight line scientist
you can try and refute this but you
can't so don't even try me baby live at
the beach what the creek oh god what is
this you're gonna cry about the brofist
again you're gonna cry I don't care you
can cry all you want you can take out
your anger and whatever you want but you
ain't getting this you ain't getting it
PewDiePie Papa here here hello papa
Gloria hurry up organ Who am I someone
help me please
oh my god when you realize bread is in
the secret life of pets Jesus Christ
it's practically him just add a little
beard here oh my god pewds let's play
the bridge entire fanbase yeah yeah and
I'll have you guys know that that guy
was a total dick he went totally trihard
even though it's my first time playing
and I didn't even swear at him I didn't
even say any bad words I think I did
this is a testimony to how much I've
grown how much strength of character how
much I've learned and improved myself
over the year still YouTube won't
recognize SMN shaking crying estimation
right now
purifies it already marzia mr. Suns out
come on lucky loincloth Kai's might say
a dating mr. B's I don't have the plague
anymore printer Hank whoops
all right let's drop this skirt there's
gonna be tea series
[Music]
[Applause]
my god
[Music]
all right it's happening and it's
happening soon
prepare your brofist prepare your
brofist I repeat this is not a drill to
prepare your brofist hit like if Felix
should record his video with his phone
phone camera actual camera oh okay I
think I get the orange meme ma'am
this is the quality you guys are getting
this is a pristine quality that I think
people expect from the biggest channel
on this website thank you very much
upload button is actually red but red it
uses quality of PewDiePie [ __ ] stop
dissing my camera okay Felix your camera
is autofocus on your mic turn on manual
focus what sir is there an issue with my
microphone
oh I'm sorry I can't hear you because my
microphone is in the way this camera has
good quality though like I don't know
why you guys are hating kids in his
videos penis thanks pretty much yeah
is this cuz they're not monetized
anyways I might as well
Thomas brush is making a beauty game go
show him some support it's looking
really good like I've been snooping a
little bit so the Thomas birch is making
a game he's live-streaming it everyday
link in description
it's crazy it's legit peers camera be
like stop stop this is my camera topic
you know what if this is what they're
they think they so clever if you guys
think you're so goddamned clever then
explain this liberals the betrayal oh
that's great
[Laughter]
goddamnit I guess I have to play happy
wheels I guess I have no choice when a
meme hears - clams my time has come it's
pretty pie version of me Ella video back
in it again thank you very much I love
it that's so great thank you guys for
another epic video moment smash like and
bro just be patient okay guys that's it
for me for now smash like merch linking
bio and I'll see you guys soon
alright real soon I'll be right back BRB
goodbye now there's not gonna be a bro
face which you guys already knew of
course instead in the meantime we're
gonna do a supplement just so you guys
don't die of depression we're gonna do
it a finger dip you can put it you can
do whatever you want with a by tuber
simulator it's now so relevant that it's
got a brand new minigame Craney egg drop
the crane and get fresh items only
available in the washing machine like
game and you say there's more of course
there is new knowledge perks new quests
and new pics links and legs guys legs
[Music]